all right happy halloween everyone as
you can see here we got the studio all
decked out for uh halloween i'm just a
festive guy you know they wanted to just
do this video game thing and i said no i
want to decorate this studio so i went
to party city i decorated the whole
thing myself uh we're going to continue
our series of me playing video games and
uh usually we have
jacob
he's my guide through these games but
after i've valiantly defeated him in one
of the great shocking twists i think in
in history he's in therapy right now and
so now we have instead
mckenna mckenna are you there you're
gonna help us with this game right yeah
i got you
okay now first of all what game are we
playing so this is five nights at
freddy's maybe i you know i i discovered
my latent
video game talent in the last last time
we did this so we'll see if we can
continue
all right i don't know what any of this
means who am i and where am i and what
am i doing you're a security guard i
basically think a haunted chuck e cheese
okay i can't move
nope this is it so the only thing that
you can do is if you look to your right
or your left at the one of the doorways
if you hit x
the x button that will close the door
yep
and then if you hit x again i'll reopen
it
do i have a weapon nope to fight the
monsters absolutely not you have the
light there so that's the circle button
okay perfect okay so that's to basically
shine the light if you see a monster and
then what if i see a monster that's it
good luck
why would i just keep the door shut the
whole time so do you see on the bottom
left of your screen there's a power left
and it says there's a percentage next to
it yeah that
is the amount of power you have left to
survive until six in the morning
so i'm a useless security guard i have
no weapon there's monsters and i'm just
gonna sit here that's correct yeah also
if you hit the l1 which is on the top of
your controller
good job that brings up your security
cameras so you'll see there that's the
yep all right you already got it you're
good
this is the worst this game is popular
what
why
okay
i'm just okay well this is great content
i hope everyone's enjoying
does anything happen in this game is
there like a is there any sort of i mean
you might want to keep your tabs up on
that security camera to just because
those they move around so you might want
to like scroll through those cameras
a little bit okay
all right what's the point of this i
thought this was like i have a
gun i go shoot the monsters
at any point in this game
is there say like a challenge or
something that i'm supposed to do or
only if absolutely necessary
gotta conserve power conserve power okay
so why do i have the camera on if i'm
trying to conserve power yeah i mean you
might want to not do it all the time you
just told me get jacob back here
all right let me turn up
i got the door open how do i turn my
light on
the circle button circle okay
all right
something's gonna come through this door
at some point then i just have to shut
the door before it comes through yes
all right and i got to make it till 6
a.m it's already 2 a.m to survive and
not die of boredom in the meantime i'm
honestly perplexed like i'm i'm not even
joking i cannot believe is this a is
this a joke is this like some kind of
prank did you guys make this game
yourself in the last two days
is that what this all is
it's already 3am i haven't even seen a
monster yet
um yeah you do
where
i i don't see anything and i don't know
why it would matter if i did see one
because i can't do anything about it
man this is thrilling i gotta say
all of the video game options that kids
have these days and this is what they
choose to play
do you see that black silhouette oh
right in front of me yeah
okay and now what do i do
just watch it okay
you're at 35
power so you might not want to have the
cameras up like this you just told me to
have the cameras on what am i supposed
to be doing not always
if i wanted to die in this game what
would i do just keep the doors open and
just let it happen okay
fine
it's almost 4am i've made i've made it
four hours through this game and
literally
what no because you just told me to
preserve power
okay yeah the creepy thing's still
standing there
okay see if there's any other movement
around
oh that's new
you're trying so hard to make this
interesting uh
mckenna i appreciate that but
i just heard something all right
is that in the game or is that you
do i sense fear
that's not me
oh
i just die
yep
well
then why did i have the cameras on i
could just so so the
i mean if the cameras are to be able to
check to see if they move around why do
i need to know what they're doing out
there all i need to know is what's
happening right outside my door i just
wait till i see them and i shut the door
and i'm good i mean if that's how you
want to play it just maybe try that
strategy
we're going to do this again really
absolutely
what i'm trying to figure out is people
watch youtube videos of other people
playing this game was that the bite of
87 to all the kids out there if you find
this interesting get a job as a real
security guard somewhere and you could
sit in an office
and stare at screens and you get paid
it's a real life
five-fingered freddy or whatever this
this game is called
why can't i just leave the door shut
they take up your power do you see how
your power is like depleting pretty
quickly now that your doors are closed
yeah why would it take up power to have
a door shut the owners of this
establishment if they know they have a
haunting problem at night
why would they set it up so that the
door so that the electricity drains by
having your
steel door shut now while i have some
kind of warning when the thing gets next
to the door will i will i be able to see
it approaching i don't know
what else is going on
crazy weather we've been having
so i just wait here until i see
something uh approaching and
do you not want to turn on the cameras
at all
because then the thing can sneak up on
me which is what happened last time
which camera are they in oh right there
so they haven't moved yet all right so
it's just those three there's another
one
honest to god i'm i'm perplexed by this
game i don't even understand
this is the worst game i've ever played
this is the worst
i can't believe it's this easy to make a
hit video game
what am i doing with my life
i can't even feel the time i got nothing
else to say about this game if you play
this game i don't know what's wrong with
you i don't know why if you're watching
this video right now i don't even know
why you're watching it i don't know i i
i'm flummoxed i'm speechless okay so
they're still hanging out oh okay one
left so we got one on the prowl here
right yes that's correct all right
now things are getting exciting where is
that uh the thing the animatronic thing
that we keep inside the building even
though we know it's
haunted and murderous 3am let's just get
to let's just get to the end of this
thing do i not have a power source i can
plug into do they not have outlets in
this i mean i see computers and
everything all over the place there's a
fan
a lot of poor planning
is involved here
i don't have enough power to keep the
doors shut but i'm running a fan
24 7 that isn't even pointed at me
okay there's that thing
where's the other oh there's two on the
prowl
i'm going to run out of battery life
well
so what am i dead now i'm a dead man
walking i'm not even walking oh there he
is
oh
is that is that it did i just die
just kill me please kill me kill me
please hey okay good thank you
i don't know about you guys but i
thoroughly enjoyed that that was
tremendous thank you mckenna for that
any time thank you for watching
everybody and uh happy halloween
okay that's it i'm done